- [Narrator] Measuring only 820 feet long
and 200 feet wide, this sleepy island
was once a central location and stop-off
for a thriving logging industry.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Sitting around one mile
outside of Rovaniemi City-the
capital city of Lapland-
is one of Finland's tiniest islands.
(soft electronic music)
The picturesque Kotisaari Island
is surrounded by the River Kemijoki.
The river was once used
as a floating channel
by the log industry until 1980,
after which the practice
of moving logs on water
was replaced by trucks.
While no one lives on the island,
it is accessible to visitors
by boat from May to October,
with roughly 500 guests making
the trek to visit per year.
To this day, the island
remains looking as it did
back in its prime.
The only hint of modern
times is the old boathouse,
which has been renovated
and turned into a tavern
for visitors to have a meal and explore
the lumberjack rest stop.
(logo dinging)